I'm super excited actually to be here
and share with you some of the
preliminary work that we're doing and
this is still kind of fresh hot off the
presses in terms of mapping skill sets
and so a tap recruit and some of the
ways that we're using different types of
embeddings so I'm a research scientist
we do a lot in my research science group
we do we sort of have two different
roles one of which is sort of kicking
the tires on new technologies and new
ways of doing things and so actually a
lot of this talk is going to be focused
on some of that work that we've done
trialing through different types of
embeddings models and dealing with
issues to do with natural language
processing and corpus generation in that
process the other part of what I do is
actually do primary research which
actually feels some of that product but
also I think there's a lot about
Travis's keynote that sort of really
starts hit home for me in terms of you
know when you find something really
interesting that you think that the
community should definitely have is
making that very publicly available and
so this is part of an ongoing sort of
effort what I'm going to be presenting
to you is still very preliminary so in
the pilot results side of it of this
sort of skill mapping and I think that's
really important just as an example set
for this type of analysis and showing
you a little bit about different types
of embeddings but I think it's also
really interesting from a personal
career standpoint things about you know
which technology should we be investing
in and how we think about writing job
descriptions is very important to that
process so yeah I should have pushed
this up the link to where the slides are
there's PDF and I will update that as we
go along
it still is here if you take a q-see
this should take you straight to the
link and I'll show this at the end as
well so I should so we are a new
york-based startup and we basically
design software around recruiting and so
we have been actually running a job
search site for about three four years
now and so we have this amazing corpus
of Job Description data
that is actually going to be the basis
of a lot of my talk and so we use that
to give you a bit of background about
why you know I find it such an interest
like it was in wine and I'll he's so
important to our work we use that to
power a smart editor that I'm going to
just show you quickly that tells you how
to write better job descriptions and we
go beyond what some people do in terms
of just language in terms of how
language impacts bias but really
understand what's the basis of a job
what are the skills that are really
important and combined with something
like I think three million salaries we
understand the job we break down the
requirements and and try and estimate
salaries and we also try and give
companies increasingly ideas about if
you put this job description up how many
candidates are you likely to get what is
your likely your chance of actually
hiring for that so we're trying to do
pipeline health monitoring but what's
central to all of these is actually
taking a corpus and breaking it down
into the actual skills and so this is
sort of what our editor looks like you
can see that sorry I don't know if this
is going to come up you can see that we
have a lot of sort of language that goes
into this there are suggestions and
there's a lot of stuff in terms of the
different types of like is in this on
one hand its language on the other side
it's about talking about the skills and
you can see that you know for example
the number of applications and things
like that we sort of track on that so
language matters a lot in job
descriptions and so you can see that a
lot of conventional job description
matching algorithms and I'm sure many of
you are receiving suggestions based on
those will take your job title and find
you something else that has the same job
title because you know that might seem
like a reasonable thing to do and you
know this is a really problematic
process because you can take the same
job title and actually sorry kraftfoods
shouldn't be the same both of them and
but it could jobs can have the same
title but they can vary dramatically in
terms of their required experience and
you'll see this when you you know if
you're a finance manager you'll be
getting both of these
of jobs in terms of the required
education one is quite a junior job in a
certain type of company and the other is
quite a senior job in another type of
company and what I think we've been able
to do is break it down into you know you
can have different titles but these are
essentially two very similar jobs and
they're also described in quite
different ways so I've highlighted some
of the ways in which language for
example consulting experience can be
described data analysis tools especially
sequel can be described quite
differently and you know we can show you
that the is in breaking it down and
actually understanding what's at the
heart of this is really critical so the
question that I wanted to talk about
today is how have data science skills
changed over time and this time point
we're talking about the last three years
and how much have we seen change and so
I'm going to go through some of the
approaches that we considered in
answering this question and some of the
pros and cons of that in the context of
natural language processing and this is
going to be very non mathematical
because I stopped doing math when I was
18 years old and so this is going to be
very practitioner focused and the sort
of packages that we've dealt with and
the pre-processing issues that we've
dealt with that's not to say I don't
enjoy doing math but if you all went to
Leland's talk I think that has got you
over the point of where I need you to be
probably you can give this talk better
than I can so how do we how do we answer
this question and what it to
conventional ways of answering this
question first is manual feature
extraction so you know if this is reg X
or other forms of tokenization and
pre-processing into a number of tags for
example this is at its heart a very
opinionated process because you're only
going to create features that you are
looking for and so it it is somewhat I
would call it supervised but that's a
very bad term to use when you in a room
with machine learning people as well but
it is sort of curated right
and so it's artisanal it's by hand and
you already know what you're looking for
the other sort of end of things is
things like type dynamic topic modeling
which are a little less
so basically you break down documents
into bags of words and you're like you
don't care about what order they come in
you know it's a matter of how much do
these words Co occur over time and how
important are they in the process of
things and what you can see here and
they've so the person and whose own
personal hero a tap recruit sort of was
one of the first people that came up
with this dynamic topic modeling and you
can see some examples of I think these
were science articles from the magazine
science on physics or atomic physics and
essentially you see from you know across
time we've seen changes in the words and
what they were able to show is that with
a lot of curation like you know in the
1800's to the 1900 in the 1880s to 1900
there's a lot of talk about matter and
then electrons pick up and then quantum
picks up I can't really personally
figure that out as a non atomic
physicist from the set of ten words that
they show here so that involves actually
a lot of looking into those you know the
things that are coming up lower along
the list and trying to really parse that
out or again being kind of opinionated
and being like these things cluster
together and so this is an example of
quantum dynamics sort of like is in this
is a topic that comes from that so both
of these approaches I think have done us
very well they are kind of manual
they're not very easy to find new things
dynamic typing modeling is a little bit
better at that process but they do
involve quite a lot of loss of context
and you know like as in there are
companies for example especially job
descriptions and you guys are probably
are aware when you search for Python
someone will describe their stack is
Python but it's a finance role right so
you're like okay well that didn't really
help me you know these are these are
problems that you can have when you're
using these sorts of approaches so the
the model that I'm sure you're all aware
of by now things that are wet embeddings
which are essentially low dimensional
transformations
unsupervised sort of text cost
clustering which is my really not very
accurate way of describing it but that's
what it represents to me and essentially
what we do is we iterate through these
you guys know corpuses and we take words
and we extract and the whole basic
intuition behind word embeddings is that
a word is judged by the by the neighbors
it keeps and so if we were interested in
a word like Python and these are some
examples to understand what would happen
we take their context and so and this is
just you know dimensionality reduction
so usually these are in 100 200 300
dimensions but now I'm just going to map
it into two dimensions just for the sake
of ease and we get a sense of okay so
object-oriented Java C++ programming
language that's great
from these sets of words and say we have
another corpus again this is our job
description corpus and you know we have
more languages right you know language
gets moved around a little bit and all
of these sort of get refined a little
bit more as we add more and more things
to it one of the big problems with what
embeddings is that every token is
represented by a single sort of in in
one way so even though language in the
context of programming means something
and it sort of doesn't actually have two
meanings but it's only you know it's
gonna get moved to the mean of those two
distances right so say you had a lot
more language so you have a lot more
translation documents language you get
moved in that direction so it does
depend on the representation of some of
those of the documents in your corpus
and that's something important to
remember one of the beauties of
embeddings is that in a totally
unsupervised way they can capture entity
relationships and I think this is just
magic I never stop being amazed by this
these are examples from the Stanford
glove project which I think show this in
amazing way so you know you can see the
difference between companies and
they're CEOs and what I find really
interesting is that the media companies
sort of cluster away from sort of more
traditional fortune 500 companies and
that sort of relationship is actually
maintained in those sorts of hierarchies
you know comparatives and superlatives
are also represented in these sorry in
these embeddings and the last thing is
in terms of and I think this is probably
best characterized example of it this
woman is to Queen as man is to for
example King and so there's a lot of
language and and whatever and
assumptions of the corpus a very
important very effectively captured and
that's both a pro and a con right I'm
sure many of you have heard of the woman
man is - computer programmer as women is
- housewife example all of the biases of
your corpus are also represented in the
beddings so that's actually a perfect
example of how you can use them beddings
- descriptive analysis and really
understand the basis of how we think
about language which is a very academic
way of thinking about it but if you're
using these embeddings in context where
they're actually going to matter there
are a whole range of D biasing tools
depending on the type of embedding and
depending on the corpus it might be
important there because we all know that
or there's a four called Ian's notion
that you know your language and your
structure sort of represent power and
impose power so I'm actually going to
talk about other types of embeddings but
I wanted to talk just a little bit about
the processing pipeline and the pros and
cons of using pre-trained embeddings
because I think a lot of people if
you're new to this space that's a very
important question there's things that
you don't necessarily keep in mind but
we've you know struggled a little bit so
you know firstly you have to generate a
corpus process that corpus we generate a
language model and then we tune that
language model and we do a final
application there are this whole process
on this left-hand side of a typical
language model generation can take
months and so what's in May
is when people have published these
embedding models they've actually
allowed you know as and have made freely
available a lot of pre-trained word
embeddings and these word embeddings
have been trained on different corpuses
with different algorithms and with
different types of vocabularies and so
this is actually very important for
those of you who aren't as familiar with
natural language processing say you want
to use an embedding and you take say the
Wikipedia corpus from glove but you want
to do sentiment analysis there's not a
lot of sentiment in Wikipedia corpuses
and so you're not going to capture that
in your outcome it's not going to Train
very well versus Twitter twitter is a
I've heard cornucopia of malformed text
and all sorts of insanity it's great for
a lot of things and and maybe that's
something that's helpful in your you
know and kind of understand your Yelp
reviews or your sentiment analysis a
Twitter the Twitter embeddings are also
really great I've heard for sort of
adversarial training of text because
it's such a cornucopia of my home text
but also you know like as in the common
crawl and Google News are also very
useful methods the one thing that I'd
say is that the token size you know you
can see that the number of tokens so the
number of words or depending on how they
process them varies and you can see that
the carbon crawl varies quite
significantly that's because there are
two implementations of it one of which
is cased and the other which is uncased
and that actually and that's something
I'm going to talk a little bit about
later the pre-processing steps that went
into these embeddings are actually
really important for you to consider and
to go into the weeds of understanding
because they're not very well documented
and so you need to make sure that if
you're going to test them out on your
text that they do follow the same
because otherwise you're going to get a
lot of unknowns and they're not going to
relate to each other so that's something
this seems kind of obvious but it's not
something that you think of when you're
like okay great in two lines of jimsim
text I've got like this embedding
working and and now I'm going to start
applying it to my algorithm
the last thing is in terms of vector
dimensionality and that again glove has
done a great job in terms of allowing
that embeddings of different
dimensionality become available and
they've trained them very well and that
also like isn't something to bear in
mind is do you need 300 dimensions and
can you run that so if you're doing
stuff off for example mobile search
maybe you don't want a 300 ml model as
part of your processing maybe your 25
will be fine and it does also depend on
the form of your corpus the one thing
that I haven't mentioned up here are
things that are character level
embedding so these are all word level
embedding so fast text for example from
Facebook is an example of a character
level embedding that's done pretty
impressive things and in some fields and
not in others and I think it has a lot
of strength in those models but it's in
our case in terms of corpus ISM trying
to understand semantics sort of
relationships it's look I found it to be
less effective so your mileage may vary
so now we get into some of the problems
with these pre-trained in embeddings and
again I sort of alluded to this earlier
this depends on your thing in our case
these are actually really very important
to us and for us to understand these
processes so like in our particular case
we had a lot of issues with casing it is
very different to IT and most of the
embeddings that come out are uncased and
so they're all lowercase so then it's
trying to understand it which happens
very frequently in in a lot of documents
versus IT which is actually very
important to us like IT support and IT
you know like as in skills you know and
so what happens is they both get
resolved to a single vector which is
probably where the it is and then it
gets down sampled a lot because that's
how these what Tyvek what deal with
frequent words there are a lot of issues
with out of vocabulary words especially
when you're using pre-trained embedding
so there are in our case we found that
you know a lot of job description data
was not found in any of the conventional
embeddings there's a lot of misspellings
for example I can tell you that the
most frequent word that we have in our
table database is manga which is not
something you find in an embedding
because people aren't normally talking
about managers they're talking about
managers so that's one of those other
sorts of things
that's the other two sort of areas that
are really important in terms of
embedding models polysemy which are
words that have multiple meanings and
multi word expressions and so like front
plus end means something very different
to front end and this front end is spelt
in a variety of different ways in job
descriptions by people who don't have
experience with front-end developers and
so if there's no easy way to like
tokenize around that or to sort of merge
them necessarily and there are actually
some I didn't have a time to show these
but there are some algorithmic ways that
you can overcome these except that the
people who write the polysemy algorithms
aren't the ones that write the ones for
multi word expressions and so you're
gonna have to resolve them somehow
yourself so with all these problems and
in our case use case these were
significant problems they may not be in
yours and so that's something just to be
aware of is that we decided okay let's
develop our own custom language models
and I want to just give a shout out to a
couple of the different corpus
processing models that I think are
libraries that I think are amazing
we use Spacey a lot and and but I've
heard great things about the open NLP
and the core NLP has gotten a lot faster
and I think Google's past emic past face
is now part of the syntax net group of
passes and these have been this is
something that you have to consider
because you can go in regex the crap out
of splitting tokens but there is some
semantic processing and there's lemmas
and things like that and dependency
parsing that might be helpful to use
more complicated systems and we've got
actually but the way that job language
is written it's so segmented there's a
lot of incomplete sentences we basically
had to write our own dependency pasta
because they doesn't work in the way
that normal English works and that's
also going to be the case for a lot of
things like you know Yelp reviews or
other types of reviews they're not know
written in normal English so that's one
thing and then the second part of it is
that's made this extraordinarily easy
are these language modeling libraries
I'm a big fan of Jen sim the stuff that
I'm going to be showing you today is
built off tensorflow so I do a lot of
the gent induce a really good job of
keeping up there embedding model to the
latest and making sure that they're
running on seeing and running really
quickly but but those are the ones that
I recommended if you're doing
distributed systems I've heard amazing
things about Amazon sage maker and I'm
sure there are others like you can
basically go down but this is today's
one I'm going to talk a bit more about
tensorflow so the last thing that I
would bear in mind with embeddings and
training your own embeddings is there
are a lot of hyper parameters to
optimize and what you optimize obviously
depends on what your output is and so if
you optimize over a small window size
which is what I showed you the example
of earlier you essentially find things
that are semantically similar so what
we're talking about are things that
substitute so you know we might not in
this room think that Python can be
substituted by Java but in the grand
scheme of things probably more so than
Esperanto right and so those are the
sorts of things if we have a larger
window size we capture more semantic
relatedness and so these are more things
like alternatives rather than
substitutes in economics speak and so
these are domain level differences so
again taking those previous examples we
see that SPSS is somehow now getting
closer to Python and distribute and you
know languages that further out and so
there are window sizes one way some of
the algorithms show differences as well
in terms of whether they catch a
semantic similarity versus relatedness
and that also depends on what your
intention is so you know maybe you want
alternatives maybe you just want to know
that Python is part of the statistical
model thing and it's very distinct from
you know finance for example RFP na
roles so we this is just an example of
I think it's a t-sne of our custom
embedding so these were like the top
thousand words and that we did based on
job description language and she
generally I found job description
language the other difficulty with it is
that you have areas that are very very
unique to each job and then you have
areas that and you guys know this a very
boiler plate you have a lot of
repetitive language and so you put that
into a topic modeling model and you get
all of the equal opportunities and perk
statements because they are the most
frequent things that come up in every
single document but that they are
different enough that they might
distinguish it so I was actually really
happy to see and I'm going to show you
these two examples and these two
clusters here of language equal
opportunity language and of you know
vision like as in perks and benefits
language and we saw that you know
there's a lot more language that goes in
there because this is a top I think
thousand words we're seeing things like
medical and dental which tend to be the
most common right that makes sense
we also found and this was actually
surprising to me was that what we call
soft skills also cluster together which
is sort of interesting because soft
skills are typically spread out
throughout a job description like they
they talked about in lots of different
ways and not in their own segment but
clearly they happen enough with each
other that they tend to sort of come
together and then the other thing is
like experience or all of the different
ways we talk about experience also costs
it together and clearly my little corpus
here has a lot of finance roles because
there's quite a few examples of that in
terms of the way that we talk about
experience so I mean we like I was
pretty happy with this model and then we
use this so I did talk about how the at
the start of the talk I was mentioning
how we want to know how they've changed
over time so it's great that I had this
Copas but what about the question of
time yes
what is adamant so the distance between
the inspectors that refused to do it so
once you know you work to the purpose
using vectors of numbers yes so they
each have so each of the words have like
a 300 dimension vector and then it
basically does a vector reduction
I mean I didn't encode the t-sne I just
use tensor flows like output of that
process to collapse them into a couple
of dimensions so it takes the 300
dimensions and it's the distance so the
distance is the it is a similarity
mentioned so the closer they are the
more similar they are the further they
are the more dissimilar they are yeah
and so that's based on the window size
as well so like if they occur within a
window size it's like a 1 versus if it
doesn't occur within the window size is
0 and then it goes from many levels of
extrapolation so I mentioned here that
the Dimmit sorry I didn't explain that
super well but that we have a whole
bunch of dimensions but we haven't
looked at time and there are a couple of
different ways of doing this and this is
actually maybe not everyone's interested
and time as a dimension but you can
substitute in your case time as any
other category that you use right so in
this case I'm showing you time I'm not
allowed to show you seniority because
that goes into a product development but
but you can imagine that that's one of
the ways that we would consider it and
so there's a couple of different ways
that people have come up with dealing
with dynamic embeddings and one of which
is just training lots of different
embeddings and then hand stitching them
together so through time and the other
alternative is training them all
together and so this is a newer
technique and i actually that's what i'm
going to be using in today's the results
I'll show you so first thing is in terms
of data this is static embeddings are
really data hungry so you're basically
training a whole embedding so I showed
you before they each embedding that's
been pre trained is like millions of
words and
or millions of words and millions of
tokens right so you need to have a
really high-quality embedding for each
of the time slices and people have done
this analysis over like you might think
okay well you have a little three time
slices how bad can that be but people
are doing this over like a hundred times
Lices and so that becomes kind of it
becomes quite significant so these two
papers for example needed billions of
words so they had to use the Google
Books corpus because it just wasn't
enough words to make that work and then
the other thing is that they require
stitching because the dimensions aren't
comparable across slices you're going to
have words in some of those slices that
aren't represented in other slices
especially if you're doing it here by
year and so how do you compute like you
know when words drop out and one of the
things with these embeddings is you
actually have to restrict your
vocabulary you do have to restrict your
vocabulary a little bit in order to get
you know like it to be effective and and
so there will be drop out on the other
hand dynamic and biddings are pretty
efficient so we have done this with
maybe a million words over three years
because I've been trying to push the
boundaries of half so a million words
over three years so three hundred
thousand words per year and we've been
trying to push the thing of how low can
you go I think the bomber and meant
article has done it with tweets like
three hundred thousand tweets over six
years or something so like it's like
egregiously low and they were all news
tweets so but I found that in general
like you don't want to go too high but
you also don't want to go too low so
it's a little bit of a Goldilocks thing
but it's one of those things that we've
just been trying to see how low we can
go so I think we did it with one and a
half million words and that actually
worked very well over three years so
five hundred thousand words per yeah the
other thing that's beautiful about this
is it doesn't require stitching in my
alignment so even if a word doesn't
happen in every single time span there
is a probabilistic function that links
it between the time spans and I'll talk
a little bit about that that's exactly
what the exponential family stuff that I
sort of alluded to in the start of my
talk the title of my talk means so first
thing any of you use in the house
oh dear you finished right yeah okay
awesome because the demand for MBAs is
one of the things that came out of our
analysis so the beauty of the embeddings
model that we tested what it does is it
gives you out you know the top words
that come out of it and we went back to
our databases and took a look an MBA is
actually like the demand for MBAs and
job descriptions is full and about 40%
which is reasonably significant not
something you want to hear if you're
$50,000 in the way of MBA school and I'm
sure we have a lot of PhDs in the house
I'm not going to ask you to stick your
hands up I put in PhD PhD didn't come
about about an analysis I put it in
because I was kind of curious like okay
well if MBAs are dropping how a PhD is
doing and what we're seeing is actually
it is dropping a little bit in all jobs
and but not as significantly as MBA and
so actually what I was surprised about
is in data science jobs then there's
like a 40% reduction in the requirements
for PhDs in those roles which I thought
was very strange so I went back and
actually did a bit of analysis of
looking at like okay so like are we
getting more do we want more people with
machine learning backgrounds or whatever
else and actually in all of those areas
there's been a shift and it's when not
actually seeing more machine learning
required in the data science roles so
it's sort of interesting that the PhD is
getting less valuable which is great for
everyone else who hasn't spent seven
years of their life doing one or
intending to do one yes so
we counted them as well so they're part
of actually the group that I counted in
the original to begin with so everything
that so I've used in my data science
jobs it's not only data scientists but
its biz is intelligence people data
engineers we counted the whole swath of
anyone who touches data in any
meaningful way and so actually I think
that's actually even more interesting so
if you're thinking about like is in from
five years ago when you're looking at
this analysts and bi people like that's
been the big boon yes so we pulled out
so I don't get to this because I was
trying to talk about just the results
but we so the embeddings actually gave
us so the dynamic embedding the output
of that process is a list of words
essentially of tokens that came out of
that process that will show the most
change and then it's incumbent on you to
go back and start looking through where
you're seeing the change and so there
are time slices so it actually with each
of those you get a different models so I
had I had three time slices had three
different models that I put into a
tensor flow projector board and just
tracked how they moved around in that
process so you kind of this it tells you
big picture and then you have to go and
figure out the small picture side of
things so the other sort of shifts that
we're seeing actually and this is very
interesting it was completely opposite
of what I thought tableau and power bi
came out of an analysis a significant
shift as notably doesn't look so big
because power bi is doing amazing things
so we'll is that well done Microsoft I
guess Elspeth
but Pal VI is seeing quite dramatic
increases so is tableau actually so data
of is skills are actually picking up in
a way and that was opposite of what I
thought I thought okay well machine
learning and deep learning and becoming
so hot and everything else but if yes
that's happening in startups but it's
not happening across the board in every
single role and actually
the biggest strength and the biggest
growth in data science skills I was
seeing or in in like a lot of you know
fortune 500 companies they're sort of
building out their marketing and sales
teams and trying to make them a lot more
data-driven Hadoop came out of our our
analysis is one of the biggest changes
and my CTO and I will like disagree
because I'm like I hear about Hadoop at
all these conferences but it makes sense
given you know AWS is kind of eating the
I hope there's no who do people here but
AWS is making it a lot easier and so
Hadoop is becoming less of a requirement
I throw in Spock as an example just to
see you know how is that doing because
we expected all of the stuff with ml to
go up and you know Spock is staying
pretty stable actually its Hadoop that's
sort of going down the changes in Spock
on significant and I'll favorite so Poe
came out of the analysis and I mean Perl
is I mean I love pearl as a linguist
it's amazing it did a lot of great
things for us but you know that's one of
the areas where it's going down and
Python is sort of eating that lunch the
one thing that my CTO didn't want me to
come and tell you about is that in data
analyst roles in data sort of scientist
roles we're seeing actually an inker
sorry it was seeing an increasing Java
surprisingly some it's not on the slide
I'm letting you know make sure your job
descriptions are effectively written as
PI data people but I think that's partly
because that this role is becoming I
mean we're seeing an increase in
scripting languages coming to the fore
in these processes and so people ask for
Python Java or C++ even if they're very
happy with Python so that might be it's
a small gain but it's been interesting
especially because I think there was
some recent stuff with Stack Overflow or
someone maybe was indeed that was
talking about like Java like doing very
very well in job listings so the last
part of my talk is talking about the
exponential family embedding so I kept
you all here till the end to talk about
to sort of tell you a little bit about
how this sort of embedding structure
fits in the broader scheme of things
so just as regression is to generalize
linear models would Tyvek is to this
family embedding the exponential family
embeddings and essentially what these
guys do what this like or what this the
intuition behind this is that
probabilistic you know adding a problem
adding some intuition about what type of
data you have so following Leyland's
talk allows you to get embeddings of
different sort of data types and I think
that's actually fascinating so what I
showed you today was with language
modeling it's essentially a form of
Bernoulli embedding so we it's binary
data of whether a word exists or not in
that context and so here there's a nod
to my whole java thing if the data point
is Java
we have context around proficiency
programming and Python and things like
that
we also have the ability to attach for
continuous data for example if you had
edges and nodes right so if you had
weighted graphs to attach a Gaussian
embedding to this so you know if you had
the number of flights that were going
out of different airports for example or
whatever is your sort of graph based
model you can attach a Gaussian
embedding so using that knowledge you
can create embeddings out of of graphs
too and the last sort of method is in
terms of pass on embedding and I found
this one to be the most exciting to be
honest because you can just take your
categorical data and we have a lot of
categorical data and create embeddings
out of it and actually that's something
that I'm going to be working on next is
to try and understand how we can do
connections between embeddings
based on categorical categories so one
of the beauties of this is and the way
that this is uses and actually I can
economics sort of market understandings
and I'm going to massacre that as a way
of describing it is to understand what
people buy together and what people
don't buy together and so this is
something I think is really helpful
because we can actually go in and use
that to sort of predict you know whether
you'll want to go to James pals talk
based on know is een in here
it's not good well based on the fact
that he doesn't even have a title in his
talk right so we can be like okay I
really like Emily's talk I like angels
talk I've got you know the accountant
ordinal data is the number of stars I
gave to those talks and if based on that
I like that it can we can impute that
based on no language so again these are
ways that we can sort of they could have
just been numbers or categories and and
we can actually sort of impute these and
these have actually been very effective
in terms of I think the group that did
this work was really good with movie
reviews and they're really like they've
been able to pop recommendation systems
based on these sorts of embeddings
because they're taking a person and
embedding of a person and embedding of
the different things that they've seen
and and serve resolve them so I think
that's amazing and and again this is
just an example of you know the way that
these sorts of embeddings have been used
to sort of figure out things that are
similar and again using in adult you
know product combinations to figure out
okay people typically buy chips with
beer or chips with frozen pizza but they
don't buy Tide Pods with cinnamon toast
necessarily although they may not have
at that point or they you won't buy two
types of soup necessarily like maybe
that's enough soup so so today's
question as my question today was like
how data science skills changed over
time I'm really happy to have shown you
some preliminary results what I showed
you today was that the flavors of static
word embeddings and like I wanted to
highlight to you guys the importance of
a corpus issue and the importance of
pre-processing those are things that
take up the most amount of time from an
NLP standpoint the things that to keep
in mind and I know that they're not the
most sexy thing to talk about like as
the math is but but I think that that's
actually really important the things
that I talked about were also
considerations for come developing
custom embedding models and that the
different types of dynamic models that
we have and the sort of things that you
can do with these dynamic models so time
in this case was an example of the
dynamic side of a Bernoulli embedding
but you can do a multi very open only
embedding and user categories for
example as your multivariate or you can
use other sorts of ordinal connections
between them
and the last thing is in terms of that
there are other members of these
embeddings that actually do very good
jobs in terms of recommendation systems
without a lot of knowledge and I think
that's fascinating I think I think
they're also men I would like for you
all to start implementing them as soon
as possible so I can see what your
results are like but with that I wanted
to thank you all hopefully I haven't
gone over time because I cannot see what
the time was and if you guys want sides
if you want to contact me I would be
happy to discuss data science skills and
other sorts of questions thank you
[Applause]